so I found a rice cooker I don't have a
link to it in front of me but there was
a rice cooker that I stumbled upon so I
love rice me too rice is
delicious it's so good and Tim like back
in the day and you'll remember this
quite well but when we when you were
into a continuous glucose monitors
and then you got me into them shortly
after
that you used to have to like manually
inject yourself with that big ass
syringe do you remember to put those in
oh so bad it was like a barbecue Fork
tongue you just stick in your abdomen it
was really bad and you would watch the
needle go in there was like no quick
action you had like push it in and push
it out and then you would get this
continuous glucose monitor and this is
like you know whatever 10 years ago and
you started doing it I thought you were
crazy and then I like copied you like
two months later and started doing it
like three months later started doing it
and one of the things I noticed and I've
noticed since my entire time doing cgms
is that rice is my biggest offender if I
eat a cup of rice my is through the
roof on the glucose side and everybody's
different everybody has different
microbiome there's a whole slew factors
on what happens here but here's the
interesting thing Toshiba who is a
trusted brand came out with a quote
unquote low carb rice cooker and I was
like what the is this like low carb
like this right we all know
rice is high carb what are they talking
about brown rice you know like all this
right even brown rice spikes me by
the way so I went I did the research and
what they've done is they created this
clever little basket they figured out
that a typical rice cooker 99.9 of rice
cookers you pour the water in cook the
rice it stews in its own water and your
rice is done you scoop it in your bowl
a bunch of the starch call it like 70 or
so percent of it is released in that
water during the the kind of the process
of actually making and cooking rice so
Toshiba invented a new
rice cooker they called their fuzzy
logic the technology rice cooker that
has a basket that lets all of the
starchy water drain to the bottom and
you end up with a much lower glycemic
load it cuts the carbs by 37 percent
and two I ate a cup of rice and I'm
telling you I can see it on my CGM it
does not Spike me nearly as much is the
full rice which I thought was pretty
awesome and I wouldn't have believed
this in anyone else but Toshiba came out
with it and I was like okay if toshiba's
gonna put their name behind it like they
must have done the research you know
yeah they're a big dog it's 179 it's
like if you're if you want to just cut a
little bit of carbs out of you or it
rice is a big offender for you this
works with like you know it works with
oatmeal it works with the whole brown
rice white rice and quinoa the whole
range of things but anyway I just
thought it was really cool it's got
1852 ratings with
four and a half out of five stars 4.6
stars out of five so people love it 300
plus have bought it in the last month
let me ask you this taste wise use it as
good is it okay a little bit on the
texture a little tiny bit on the texture
but like I'd say like call it a maybe
five to seven percent Delta from what
you're normally experiencing on Rice so
it's you're not pissed it's fine yeah
nobody's complaining
that's a big deal it's a big deal I
love rice there are so many
carbs that I can I'm like whatever I can
do without it I love rice oh my god do I
love rice